Навпроти мене Грігол Вашадзе, політик, кандидат в президенти  Грузії від опозиції.
Під час правління Міхеіла Саакашвілі з 2008 по 2012 роки
Вашадзе обіймав посаду міністра закордонних справ.
Пане Вашадзе, дякую за інтерв'ю та вітаємо в програмі.
Дуже дякую.
У Вашій біографії є один дуже цікавий факт.
Протягом багатьох років у Вас було подвійне громадянство - російське та грузинське.
Ви відмовилися від російського громадянства у 2008 році.
Чи не могли б розповісти, чому Ви ухвалили рішення
відмовитися від російського громадянства?
Знаєте, у мене, взагалі-то, був лише один паспорт, лише російський.
жив у Москві з 1976 по 1993 рік.
Коли Радянський Союз розпався у 1991 році, я був у Сполучених Штатах.
Я не пам'ятаю, скільки часу я там перебував, п'ять або шість місяців.
А коли повернувся, я виявив, що я вже російський громадянин,
тому що Радянського Союзу більше не існує.
Потім у 2004-му я повернувся в Грузію та отримав уже грузинське громадянство.
У 2005, або ще в 2004-му. Не важливо.
А потім, після того, як Росія почала війну з Грузією,
я відправив свій паспорт пану Медведєву.
Я сказав, що відмовляюся від свого російського громадянства,
тому що не можу терпіти такого ставлення Кремля до незалежності моєї країни, моєї нації.
Кремлю знадобилося 11 місяців, щоб вирішити,
чи готові вони дозволити мені вийти з російського громадянства.
Але врешті-решт вони це зробили.
І нині у мене є лише один паспорт  - грузинський.
І я не сумніваюся в тому, що моє рішення відмовитися від російського громадянства
було правильним та дуже своєчасним.
Ви користуєтеся підтримкою на цих президентських виборах
колишнього президента Грузії Міхеіла Саакашвілі.
Він один з Ваших палких прихильників.
Його підтримка в другому турі буде швидше перевагою чи недоліком?
Усі в Грузії знають, що я абсолютно незалежний і був незалежним,
коли працював в уряді з 2008 по 2012 рік.
Я навіть не був членом партії.
Я категорично відмовився вступати в партію,
тому що у мене уже було безліч проблем з партійною дисципліною. І я про це відверто говорив.
Що стосується президента Саакашвілі, то спробую коротко описати своє ставлення до нього.
Він мій друг. І як будь-який розумний громадyнин Грузії я вдячний йому за те,
що він перетворив цю територію на сучасну державу.
Він повинен мати право жити в Грузії. Він повинен отримати назад своє грузинське громадянство.
Якщо у правоохоронних органів чи у судової системи є питання до нього,  він повинен на них відповісти.
І якщо він хоче будувати тут своє політичне майбутнє, тоді рішення за грузинською нацією.
Якщо Ви станете президентом, Ви повернете йому грузинське громадянство?
Абсолютно так. Поверну.
Ви помилуєте його?
Так, я це зроблю. Але я не збираюся помилувати його одного. Я помилую всіх політичних в'язнів.
І будь-ласка, не упустіть це, бо деякі грузинські телеканали вирізають другу частину фрази.
Я це не виріжу.
Звісно, ні. Я помилую президента Саакашвілі, я помилую усіх політичних в'язнів,
я помилую всіх ув'язнених жінок, які не зробили чогось екстраординарного і в яких є діти.
Я збираюся зробити це дуже швидко. Імовірно, протягом перших двох-трьох місяцІв.
Тому що я знаю, що відбувається у в'язницях.
Як юрист я хочу, щоб справедливість взяла гору. І так і буде.
Тому що третій президент Грузії отримає право тут проживати.
Скористається він цим правом чи ні - залежить від нього.
Його політичне майбутнє, знову ж, залежить від грузинського народу, від громадян країни.
Але можливість жити тут у своєму будиночку в Кварелі - це те, що ми йому винні.
Ви згадали, що Ви із Саакашвілі друзі.
Але він відомий тим, що час від часу різко критикує своїх учорашніх союзників.
Наскільки реалістичний сценарій того, що між вами,
якщо Ви, звісно, станете президентом, і ним може виникнути конфлікт?
Знаєте, це таке дивне запитання, тому що, чесно кажучи, я так не вважаю.
Я ніколи не вибирав собі друзів, виходячи з їхніх політичних уподобань.
Але у вас обох є політичні інтереси. Це те, що я мала на увазі.
Так. Він мій друг, і якщо виникнуть протиріччя між моїми переконаннями і його переконаннями,
я зроблю все, щоб зберегти дружбу.
Цілком можливо, що наші політичні шляхи можуть розійтися.
Але в такому випадку я не буду кричати телевізійникам, як деякі інші його друзі,
що Міша Саакашвілі єдиний, хто в усьому винен, що Міша Саакашвілі диктатор,
що Міша Саакашвілі лише заважав, коли ці хлопці робили свою справу з перетворення Грузії.
Як на мене - це смішно.
А він не диктатор, він справжній демократ?
Так. Абсолютно. Який диктатор коли-небудь мирно віддавав свою владу.
Пане Вашадзе, ви абсолютно праві, що навели саме цей приклад,
який ілюструє демократичність пана Саакашвілі, що він забезпечив мирний перехід влади.
Це поза сумнівом, і я думаю,
це заклало основу спадкоємності чинної демократичної традиції в Грузії.
Але його критики кажуть, що коли він був при владі,
він був неймовірно жорстокий щодо своїх політичних опонентів.
Він саджав їх у тюрму, і були численні випадки порушення прав людини.
У 2007 була демонстрація, мирна демонстрація, яка була розігнана із застосуванням жорстких методів.
Що ви можете відповісти на цю критику?
Коли ми говоримо про помилки, ми повинні відрізняти помилки від диктатури.
Якщо ви хочете згадати 2007 рік, то так, це була дуже сумна подія в нашій історії,
але знову ж - ніхто не був у змозі розігнати цей величезний натовп біля парламенту.
У них було конституційне право на збори.
Вони мали конституційне право висловлювати свою думку та свобода слова.
Я не був учасником тоді, я був простим громадянином, тому я не знаю історію зсередини.
Але є два погляди - одні кажуть, що це була спроба заколоту,
а інші - що мирна демонстрація була жорстко притиснута з перевищенням сили.
Я можу сказати свою точку зору - рейд,
який здійснили проти і всередині телекомпанії ІМЕДІ, був жахливою помилкою.
Величезною політичною помилкою. І я думаю, що в багатьох моментах це було початком кінця.
І моя відповідь про Мішу, я би сказав вам зі 100-відсотковою впевненістю,
що він надто молодий, щоб бути списаним.
Хоча як людині, яка провела 5 чи 6 років в імміграції,
йому доведеться звикати до цієї країни з нуля, тому що ця країна змінилася, значно змінилася.
Що Ви розумієте під змінами. Грузія досі є демократією?
Так.
Вона стала більш демократичною відтоді, як пішов Саакашвілі?
Ні, вона стала менш демократичною.
Перевірте факти втручання в результати виборів або подивіться на телевізійний ринок Грузії,
де є лише один впливовий незалежний телеканал Руставі-2.
Якщо ви подивитеся на інформаційну картину в інтернеті, то виявите,
що близько 99% інформаційних сайтів контролює так звана "Грузинська мрія" та Іванішвілі.
Звісно, вона менш демократична, хоча основні свободи зберігаються.
А Іванішвілі і його так звана "Грузинська мрія" - це вітрянка.
Знаєте, що це таке?
І після трьох перших днів температури понад 40-41 градусів, настає швидке відновлення.
Тож ми нині "переносимо" Іванішвілі як вітрянку.
Якщо Ви виграєте вибори, якої реакції очікуєте від російського уряду?
Я п'ять років свого життя віддав боротьбі з Росією та мав успіх,
залишивши Росію в ганебній кампанії Венесуели, Сирії та Нікарагуа.
Тобто Ви не плануєте зустрічатися з Путіним для обговорення майбутнього окупованих територій?
Ні, тому що я знаю, якою буде реакція Кремля.
Ми з вами говоримо про вашу країну. Ви росіянка.
Грузія своєю незалежністю відібрала у Росії стратегічну роль на Кавказі.
А Росія бореться за те, щоб її повернути.
Але проблема в тому, що окуповані регіони - це не вирішення російської проблеми.
Вони як валіза без ручки, знаєте, ви не можете викинути її, бо соромно,
але й зберігати не можете, бо вона вам не потрібна.
Ви лише витрачаєте на це гроші.
Ось, що відбувається. Тож не знаю, якою буде реакція Кремля. І чесно кажучи, мені байдуже.
Пане Вашадзе, я хочу подякувати Вам за інтерв'ю і Ваш час.
Дякую, було дуже приємно.